how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where each week you
all submit your theories and I choose
five to go over each week and you all
vote on which one you thought was your
favorite and then at the end of the
month you all vote on which one you
thought was the overall best for the
month the winner gets the monthly prize
which right now is to IMAX tickets so
you can go see spider-man far from home
in IMAX or go re-watch Avengers in game
which if you have not heard they are
doing a rerelease with seven minutes of
new footage including a post-credits
scene and a tribute to Stan Lee at the
end so if you would like to submit your
own theory for a chance to be on an
episode of Theory Thursday you can find
the email to send it to and the
instructions in the description down
below big shout out to alfredo Moscow so
for being the winner of Theory Thursday
for the month of May afraid a one the
month of May with his theory about the
multiverse collision and the battle
world and congrats to Andrew Mullen you
for being last week's winner of Theory
Thursday with his spider-man far from
home theory Congrats Andrew you are now
eligible to win the monthly press also
if you're interested in other theories
that aren't related to Marvel's such as
Star Wars DC Star Trek etc you can check
out my other channel cosmic culture
alright let's dive into some theories we
have some really good ones this week the
first theory comes from Kristen on del
with the YouTube channel named Chris de
artists and Kristen has a theory about
how the Fantastic Four will be
introduced into the MCU Kristen says
that the Fantastic Four are from the
future 2025 and some of Tony Stark's
inheritance when he died went towards
Reed Richard and his wife who are both
scientist slash explorers they used some
of Tony's technology and equipment to
explore the quantum realm and they end
up getting trapped in there for a very
long time while they're stuck in the
quantum realm they end up evolving and
the evolution is what ends up giving
them their powers just like Janet Van
Dyne and ant-man and the wasp
however they have no way to get out of
the quantum realm so they just stay
there with their powers they use their
powers for good make a home there and
become somewhat of a quantum realm
Avengers the Fantastic Four and the city
that we saw in ant-man and the wasp and
the quantum realm is actually the Baxter
building
and then in ant-man and the wasp 3 or
the post-credits scene for ant-man and
the wasp they could introduce the
Fantastic Four and get them out of the
quantum realm this is a really good
theory because in the comics the
Fantastic Four are directly connected
with the quantum realm and of course in
the MCU ant-man and ant-man and the wasp
and Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne are also
directly connected with the quantum
realm obviously but also something you
have to keep in mind is the director for
ant-man and ant-man and the wasp Peyton
Reed he is a huge Fantastic Four fan in
fact he pitched a script to Fox for the
Fantastic Four 2000 on the rights to
them now fortunately for us Fox wasn't
really interested at the time which
means that we could potentially get
Payton Reed's Fantastic Four movie which
means they could potentially be
introduced in the next ant-man in the
wasp movie so this theory about the
Fantastic Four ties very nicely into the
current MCU so that is theory number one
on to theory number two theory number
two comes from comic fan productions and
they have a theory about how Steve
Rogers and Tony Stark could return to
the MCU comic fan productions theories
on how Steve Rogers and Tony Stark will
return are based off of comic arcs they
say that Steve Rogers will return to the
MCU in the following way when you read
the secret Empire storyline old man cap
grabs the infinity cube / tesseract and
it gives him the desire of his heart and
what if when Captain America returns the
space stone / the tesseract it seized
the desires of his heart and then in the
future when he's old man cap it ends up
turning him back to a young Captain
America and then how to bring back Tony
Stark there is an old comic book arc
where Tony Stark dies and the Avengers
go back in time and bring back a young
Tony into the Marvel Canon this could
easily be done now in the MCU since time
travel as possible this theory is
certainly a good way to bring back both
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark
especially with time-travel now being
involved in a multiverse as well
although I do think that Tony Stark is
going to remain dead it is possible if
at any point in time they wanted to
bring him back they could through
time-travel so that is theory number two
on to number three theory 3 comes from
user blackout studios and black out has
a theory about Mysterio and spider-man
far from home and the multiverse black
out studio says that there was a lot the
Avengers changed when they went back in
time not just taking the Infinity stones
but taking Mjolnir
particles Loki escaping and so on there
were several different events that were
altered which caused many different
alternate universes to form and blackout
studios this theory is about how the
multiverse formed in spider-man far from
home the theory states that maybe
Mysteria was created because the ancient
one chose him over dr. strange because a
professor halts explanation making him
the master of the mystic arts and not
actually illusions like he is in the
comics the fire elemental could be
eldritch Killian from Iron Man 3 this
could happen because Stark was hunting
Loki because he took the tesseract and
the extremists transformed him into it
the water monster could be the working
of Namor because infinity war or endgame
never happened in this different
universe that means Wakanda actually
handled the underwater earthquakes that
were mentioned in Avengers endgame which
means they probably fought Atlantis the
rock monster could be the doing of Loki
he got the space stone so he can go to
the ice giants and make them invade
earth he infused rocks with the Giants
to make them stronger and since the snap
tore a hole in the timeline maybe all of
these beans were plucked out of their
timelines and transported to the main
timeline this is certainly an
interesting theory but the really cool
thing is that since the snap created a
multiverse anything is really possible
now a lot of people think that Mysterio
is somehow trained in the mystic arts
and in an alternate universe it is
definitely possible
his powers are very similar to dr.
Strange's and loki would probably still
want to invade earth he just tried and
failed and that would probably make loki
pretty upset and loki is definitely one
to seek vengeance so it wouldn't be that
surprising if he went and got some of
his people to attack earth so that is
theory number three on to number four
theory number four comes from Kevin Pugh
and he proposes the theory that maybe
old man captain at the end of Avengers
endgame isn't the real Captain America
Kevin says that what if old man captain
at the end of endgame wasn't really him
what if he was a scroll that
conversation between Captain America and
Falcon sets up a new Captain America but
maybe that was all according to plan so
much could have gone wrong and captain's
attempt to return the stones what if he
got all but one replaced the power stone
perhaps he left the power stone as the
last one to return and when he went to
return it got ambushed by the scrolls
and what if when they ambushed him they
overpowered him took him captive
took the power stone then once girl took
the form of Captain America took a fake
shield and went to the present time many
people have noticed that the shield that
old man cap gets the Falcon at the end
of in-game looks a little bit different
maybe because it's not really made of
vibranium it's a fake fake Captain
America could open the door to the
eventual secret invasion down the line
and this way if they want to bring Chris
Evans back as Captain America they have
an explanation for why he's so young and
where he's been this is a good theory
because it's definitely plausible this
could definitely happen in the MCU and
who's to say that Captain America
returned all of the stones perfectly
without any problem whatsoever
there were a few complications the first
time they went back in time so who's to
say that Captain America got it right
the first time he went back to return
the stones and this is also a great way
to set up Secret Invasion especially
with Captain Marvel introducing the
scroll
so that is theory number four on to the
final Theory number five theory number
five comes from Ricky Rodriguez and he
says that new cosmic villains will now
come out from hiding and rage chaos
throughout the universe Ricky says that
there were three cosmic forces keeping
the universe in order that being Odin
and the Asgardians Pharaohs and the
Black Order and the Nova Corps of xander
these forces were feared throughout the
universe and kept a lot of dark forces
and villains from rising up and gaining
power and although Thanos and his army
were a darker force he still kept order
throughout the universe in his own
weight which is more twisted and cold
than the Asgardians and the Nova Corps
now all three forces are gone from the
events of Ragnarok and Finity warrant
endgame and now the dark forces will
find out news that fan house Odin and
the Nova Corps are gone and see this as
an opportunity to come out from the
shadows and either rage chaos fear and
destruction villains like
Nilus Galactus the brood and the MC use
version of the symbiotes etc' are just
some of the villains that will pop up
and could be possible villains for the
future of the MCU that will be what
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 story will
be centered around the guardians trying
to bring order to the universe and fill
in the position of Nova Corps and Odin
this is a really good theory and it
makes a lot of sense because the Nova
Corps Odin and the Asgardians and
fanouts in his own weird way did keep
order in the universe and they were all
feared but now they're gone and there's
not a lot to stop very powerful
forces from coming and invading the
universe and we already know that Marvel
was going to put the Living Tribunal a
cosmic entity in Avengers in games so
they could be thinking about bringing
the cosmic entities in and now Disney
and Marvel finally have the rights to
use Galactus and the Silver Surfer in
the MCU so perhaps now that Fanus is
gone Galactus will come so that does it
for this week's theories for Theory
Thursday let's do a quick recap theory
number one is that the Fantastic Four
will be introduced in the quantum realm
and in the next ant-man and the wasp
movie theory number two is a theory
about how Steve Rogers and Tony Stark
can return to the MCU theory number
three is that in an alternate universe
Mysteria was picked by the ancient one
over dr. strange because of what
professor hulk told her and each
elemental comes from a different
universe theory number four is that old
man captain at the end of endgame is
actually a scroll which will eventually
set up secret invasion and theory number
five is that with Odin and the
Asgardians Fano sand the black order and
the Nova Corps gone the dark forces and
cosmic villains of the universe will
come out from hiding and rage chaos
throughout the universe so that is it
for this week's theories be sure to vote
on which one you think is your favorite
and again if you would like to submit a
theory of your own for a chance to end
up in an episode of Theory Thursdays you
can find the email to send it to and the
instructions in the description down
below be sure to subscribe so you can
say up-to-date on episodes of Theory
Thursdays and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to Marvel and as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll see you next Thursday will
fool off